pendant ce temps l'inquiétude demeure
autour de la centrale nucléaire de
zappos ridja touchées par des
bombardements ces derniers jours moscou
et kiev s'en rejettent la faute les
experts de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique sont attendus d'ici
quelques heures sur place ont fait le
point sur la situation avec notre envoyé
spécial james hendry il se trouve
justement à cinq kilomètres de là
centrale se trouve effectivement
derrière moi peut-être 5 2 7 km à vol
d'oiseau de l'autre côté du nid après
cette route que vous voyez mène
directement à nico paul nikopol c'est la
localité qui se trouve juste en face sur
l'autre rive de ce fleuve face à la
centrale est en fête et bien nous avons
été arrêtés par les militaires au bout
de cette route à un check point qui nous
ont expliqués et bien que la zone était
fermée à la presse jusqu'au 31 août en
réalité fermé à toute personne qui n'est
pas de la ville uni qui n'a pas une
raison impérieuse de s'y rendre on nous
explique et bien que c'est à cause d'une
recrudescence des combats dans le
secteur et que c'est pour notre sécurité
mais effectivement il apparaît bien que
les autorités ont décidé et bien tout
simplement de fermer la zone d'ici on a
entendu des départs d'artillerie
ç'a donc des tiers a priori mené par
l'armée ukrainienne
mais effectivement on ne peut pas
accéder directement à cette ville pour
l'instant alors pour rappel
effectivement cette inspection de l'aiea
doit se tenir dans les heures qui
viennent en réalité un c'est à dire que
il est question qu'ils arrivent à partir
de mercredi c'est tout ce que nous avons
entendu évidemment il n'y a aucune
précision sur le calendrier exact de
cette visite ils viennent vérifier
l'intégrité structurelle de cette
centrale on vient d'entendre un départ
de feu 1 de cette centrale qui se trouve
non loin également vérifier les
conditions dans lesquelles travaille le
millier d'ingénieurs ukrainien qui
travaillent sous comme on contrôle russe
à l'heure actuelle dans la centrale pour
savoir si oui ou non il y à un risque
nucléaire qui plane sur l'europe à ce
stade pour rappel c'est la plus grande
centrale électrique nucléaire d'europe